estos turistas están a punto de lanzarse
al agua y se preparan con aletas y
snorkel es durante una excursión a
magnetic island una isla situada en
frente de la costa de queensland en
australia los encargados del tour es
stefani y adam innings les van a mostrar
una de las siete maravillas naturales
del mundo la gran barrera de coral es
pero era una tortuga y algunos peces de
colores pero el mundo subacuático que
los espera
es cada vez más vulnerable al cambio
climático en marzo el sistema de
arrecife de coral más grande del mundo
sufrió un nuevo golpe otro episodio de
blanqueamiento masivo que tuvo un
impacto en más del 90% de los corales
monitoreados
cuando ocurre un episodio de
blanqueamiento entramos al agua y vemos
qué efecto tuvo todos los corales son
como nuevos bebés entonces vamos y
realizamos cada pequeño recife de parche
el arrecife genera más de 4.300 millones
de euros anuales para la economía
australiana y el turismo marino produce
más de 64 mil empleos
contamos con que los clientes puedan
venir a visitar y ver el arrecife
pero esos ingresos están en juego ante
las cada vez más frecuentes e intensas
olas de calor marinas este último
episodio de blanqueamiento es el sexto
desde
1998 sin embargo los corales pueden
sobrevivir
una persona puede sufrir un golpe de
calor y siempre y cuando se enfríe lo
suficientemente rápido estará bien el
blanqueamiento de corales es exactamente
igual es una condición de estrés que
sería mejor evitar del todo pero sólo
por padecer esa condición de estrés el
golpe de calor no significa que
necesariamente uno se vaya a morir el
recién elegido gobierno laborista
gastará más de 800 millones de euros
para proteger el arrecife una
financiación que se extenderá durante
los próximos nueve años cerca de dos
tercios de esas sumas son para trabajar
con los granjeros para mejorar las
prácticas de uso del suelo y reducir la
contaminación que las tierras agrícolas
generan en la gran barrera de coral en
esta extensa granja de 13.000 hectáreas
hay más de 2.500 reses garlow moulin y
su familia fueron de los primeros en la
región en implementar el pastoreo
controlado hace más de 20 años tiempo
después otras granjas situadas cerca del
arrecife también adoptaron esta práctica
sostenible
los principios de pastoreo que utilizan
se inspiran en los grandes rebaños
migratorios de áfrica donde los rebaños
llegan pero después se van hacia el país
poder operarse eso hace una gran
diferencia se mantiene el terreno
cubierto y se frena la erosión de los
suelos
la propiedad forma parte de una triple
cuenca fluvial que arrastra la mayor
carga de sedimentos hasta la recife a
unos 70 kilómetros
la hierba protege el suelo de la erosión
por agua
descubrimos que si había suelo sin
vegetación cuando llovía se iba hacia
los riachuelos y ríos
pero las medidas tomadas para mejorar
las prácticas ganaderas son tan sólo una
parte de la solución es una gran idea
hacerlo pero no se está tratando el
problema principal que es el
calentamiento global muchos insisten en
medidas más firmes y urgentes para
reducir los gases de efecto invernadero
y prevenir otros blanqueamientos masivos
es como si 10 ciclones severos de
categoría 5 se estuvieran acercando
tomados de las manos en términos de la
magnitud y de la gravedad de la pérdida
de los corales se necesita alrededor de
una década para que los corales que
crecen más rápido de muestras de una
recuperación medianamente decente ya no
tenemos esa cantidad de tiempo entre
estos episodios recurrentes de
blanqueamiento causados por el
calentamiento global
durante el último ejercicio financiero
las autoridades federales y estatales
destinaron 7 mil 800 millones de euros
en subsidios para combustibles fósiles
aunque el nuevo gobierno tiene objetivos
climáticos más ambiciosos que la
coalición que estuvo en el poder durante
nueve años afirma que seguirá apoyando y
expandiendo las exportaciones de
combustible fósil del país
aún a pesar de las promesas de convertir
a australia en una superpotencia de las
energías renovables
este parque solar cerca de townsville en
queensland inició su actividad en 2018
creo que mucho potencial para el
crecimiento solar en australia aquí
tenemos una gran superficie de tierra y
hace mucho sol es una nueva tecnología
en australia y a medida que se
desarrolle estoy seguro de que habrá
cada vez más parques solares por todo el
país
si bien el ímpetu por la energía limpia
está creciendo es poco probable que el
país se decida por esa alternativa con
el fin de eliminar las centrales
eléctricas de carbón para 2030 los
científicos del clima afirman que el
planeta debe limitar su calentamiento
global a 1.5 grados celsius
hasta arenys
todos somos los guardianes de los
arrecifes que hay en el mundo y pensar
en sumergirse en el agua y no ver nada
es algo que realmente me asusta
se estima que con un aumento de la
temperatura de 1.5 grados celsius se
perderá entre 70 y 90 por ciento de los
arrecifes de coral del mundo y alcanzar
los 2 grados los expertos advierten que
desaparecerá el
99%